blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to
blinkist.com pakman all right today
we're going to start by looking at how
many of his hundred day promises joe
biden has accomplished as president
either partially or fully and i think
it makes sense to say at the outset that
we will evaluate whether he did the
things he promised to do
the the question of whether he promised
to do the right things is a separate one
so like as an example if joe biden
promised to
cancel ten thousand dollars in student
debt and did it but you think he should
have done fifty thousand these are two
different questions did he promise the
right thing and did he achieve the thing
that he promised but let's just jump
right into it starting with climate the
npr and the ap have really good trackers
on this and i encourage you to check out
i'm looking at the associated press
tracker and it's very very good so on
climate
four promises joe biden has kept he has
taken executive action to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions he did rejoin
the paris climate accord he supported an
amendment to the montreal protocol to
curb uh hfcs and he has convened a world
climate summit which recently took place
he did those four things that he
promised he has not yet done
infrastructure that will sort of be
uh
done in a way that takes into account
the big picture climate picture uh he he
just hasn't done infrastructure yet he
has not taken steps to conver conserve
30 of us lands and waters by 2030 and he
has not received emission reductions
commitments from the shipping and
aviation industry on the economy joe
biden has accomplished four of his five
promises he has extended a pause on
student loan payments
he did pandemic relief 1.9 trillion
he did review the u.s supply chain for
vulnerabilities in key sectors those
have been identified he has taken steps
to strengthen by american measures and
he has not yet increased the corporate
tax rate so four out of five on economy
and taxes now you might be saying well
hold on he made other promises
economically yes but they were not
hundred-day promises we're looking at
hundred-day promises
on government functioning he has done
three of four he tightened ethics rules
he insulated the justice department from
politics he eased federal unionization
restrictions he did not restore rules
that were weakened by donald trump on
gun control he's really done nothing yet
he promised to send congress a gun
control bill it's sort of partially been
met but it's not been completed
he uh promised to reauthorize the
violence against women act it's on its
way but it has not yet been done
um commissioning an attorney general
report to restructure agencies to
enforce gun laws he's gotten merrick
garland started on it
but it's not yet been done
um and uh he also promised an fbi report
on how to tighten gun purchase uh
background check check loopholes has not
been done
healthcare he made eight promises for
his first hundred days and he's done
five he did do a mask mandate on federal
property
he rejoined the world health
organization
he set up a hundred mass vaccination
centers
he vaccinated 100 million americans
actually 200 million and he did deploy
mobile vaccination clinics he has not
expanded healthcare access in a
meaningful way yet
uh and he has not outlined new pandemic
measures for future pandemics that's
been requested it's sort of you could
say in process and he has not yet
reopened most elementary and middle
schools on housing he said he would
pause evictions and foreclosures and he
did and there were some other strategic
things like uh coming up with a strategy
to make housing a right that's not yet
been done so he did do one thing on
housing
immigration is a tough one there were a
lot of immigration promises made in fact
17
many have not been accomplished the
naturalization process hasn't been
streamlined
um
increases to the amount of of refugees
have not taken place but he did send
congress an immigration bill which he
promised to do
he did revise deportation criteria
although many people would say yeah they
were revised but it's not nearly enough
he did take steps to re reunite
separated migrant families he did end
the travel ban he did stop deportations
for certain groups and with a lot of
these with the immigration stuff the
devil's really in the details where
the promise is very open-ended
so you and i would look at what's going
on with deportations and we would say
there's still a ton of them going on the
promise was to stop deportations for
certain groups
and he did sign a memo
on that but we i don't feel it's nearly
enough he stopped border wall
construction
reversed the public charge rule for
immigrants and and then there's a whole
bunch of other stuff that is sort of
arguably in progress he's asked for it
hasn't really happened uh he promised to
freeze deportations for a hundred days
remember he did it but then it was
blocked by a judge
uh on inequality basically nothing has
yet been done
uh he made 12 promises the only one
that's been accomplished is creating a
uh
a working group a union issues working
group
to deliver a plan on increasing union
membership that's been done all the
other stuff hasn't you know addressing
systemic racism in u.s institutions
signing the equality act uh appointing a
commission to study sexual assault in
the military these are things that joe
biden has
said he wants done while being president
so so they're marked as in process they
have not yet been done
um and then on national security joe
biden promised to rejoin the iran
nuclear deal um he has he has started
that process it has not happened so how
do you grade his promises i i mean you
know the the thing that's tough about
this is a lot of these promises we all
knew were never going to happen much
like with trump we knew where trump was
never going to build a wall across the
entire border and get mexico to pay for
it in his first four years this was
never going to happen and he failed and
so it was a promise he failed to deliver
on
trump was never going to pay off the
national debt in four years and of
course he blew it up actually
joe biden's promises were more
reasonable but some were still clearly
not going to happen so
if we just grade him on a percentage
basis it's like a c
if we grade him based on
his intentions via things he signed
orders on but obviously take longer than
100 days and we account for all of the
realities
it's probably like a b-plus
uh but but with all of these things the
questions really are
how do we interpret his intention to do
something versus the practicality when
you understand that there are other
players involved you're going to have to
tell me how to evaluate that and
ultimately voters are going to decide
some great things done
and compared to many other presidents
this has been one of the most productive
first hundred days compared to all the
things he promised if you just you don't
do a curve of any kind that accounts for
practical difficulties
it's like he's done kind of you know
half the stuff or something like that so
let me know your thoughts and how we
should be evaluating it in many ways the
stock market is not the economy we've
talked about that endlessly over the
years the stock market tells you one
very specific thing it relates to a few
other aspects of the economy but stocks
can do well while things can be not so
good for much of the american people now
that being said donald trump and many of
his followers hung their hats their maga
hats on stock market performance and
more than that donald trump told us if
joe biden wins
the stock market will collapse 401ks
would be worth nothing we never believed
it in advance because the stock market
generally does better during democratic
presidents than republican presidents
but now we know it didn't happen because
the stock market has done better during
joe biden's first hundred days than
during any president's first hundred
days in the last 75 years remember when
uh trump said this
they said
if i'm elected if he's elected the stock
market will crash well it didn't happen
going back to world war ii the s p 500
the broadest of the major three indices
posted a better return during joe
biden's first hundred days than during
any other president dating back 75 years
the s p 500 is up 25
since joe biden was inaugurated it was
up under 15 under donald trump during
the same period previously the record
for the hundred day mark was 20
under john f kennedy now of course you
will hear from those who don't want to
accept this that this is only because
joe biden was handed a perfectly timed
covid recovery but that's wrong the
stock market recovery to pre-covered
levels was complete before trump left
office that's not what is going on you
will hear well it's because of the
so-called money printing that the
coveted stimulus that joe biden's
coveted stimulus did no that was
relatively recent and that has an impact
that they takes time to be seen and
understood and of course you will also
hear from right wingers saying well
things might look good now but wait
until joe biden jacks up the corporate
tax rate and the capital gains rate and
the income tax rate and then things are
going to implode probably not analysts
at jp morgan
have looked at the proposal and have
said you know that it should really be a
modest impact so to refresh
the stock market is not the economy but
when one side says basically it is
and it will crash under biden
and the opposite happens that's very
much worth doing a reality check on
here's more context on that trump quote
about the stock market from earlier
mr president i have to move on to the
next question
if i'm elected if he's elected the stock
market will crash okay let's get into
the next question
very quickly look
the idea that the stock market is
booming is his only measure of what's
happening where i come from in scranton
and claim on that people don't live off
of the stock market just in the uh just
in the last three three years during
this crisis
the billionaires in this country made
according to the wall street 700 billion
more dollars
700 billion more dollars because that's
his only measure what happens to the
ordinary people out there what happens
to them so the point is joe biden has
not been hanging his hat on stock market
performance that's likely why joe biden
hasn't been bragging about it on twitter
trump did hang his hat on stock market
performance and was completely and
totally wrong on what would happen and
joe biden's first hundred day
performance is significantly better
about two-thirds better
than donald trump that's not an error 25
percent versus 15 percent that is 67
percent better under joe biden so don't
fall for it yes they'll have some
talking point to try to talk their way
out of it but just follow the data and
look at history as well
let me know your thoughts did you ever
believe the stock market was going to
crash under joe biden you can find me on
twitter at deepakman let me know
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
remember that the david pakman show is
primarily made possible by viewers and
listeners like you we have a little old
membership program which you can sign up
for at joinpackman.com you get a bunch
of great perks including commercial free
audio and video streams of each daily
show as well as a members only bonus
show just for you every single day
sign up at joinpackman.com use the
coupon code if you want that code is
better21 there's a really interesting
piece i saw yesterday morning in the
hill written by alexander bolton it's
called republican worries republican
party worries fiscal conservatism is
losing its rallying cry
and the article says a few interesting
things the big picture of which is
the fiscal conservatism that for so long
was a big piece of the republican party
mantra or ideology or policy framework
maybe losing its sort of power and
strength
as a unifying factor for the republican
party
and bolton writes instead culture war
issues like immigration religious
freedom lgbtq rights big tech and black
lives matter are taking center stage in
conservative politics saying that quote
the initial shift in republican
political priorities away from belt
tightening coincided with the demise of
the tea party the dominant force in the
20 2010 midterm elections and the rise
of now former president trump who
presided over an 8 trillion dollar
increase in the national debt i agree
this is happening i think that it
actually started far earlier
in a sense
reagan
while very fiscal conservatism focused
started the path of the shift to the
cultural and social issues reagan did it
by starting to talk about the welfare
queen with the cadillac and all the kids
just to make some food stamp money and
that led to newt gingrich who pushed the
republican party more in the direction
of the culture and social issues which
then led to george w bush who was
essentially incompetent economically and
from a foreign policy standpoint
but was big on he's against abortion and
he's born again and all this different
stuff
and then we got to uh donald trump so so
i while i completely agree that this
happened i think the timeline is
actually a much more nuanced and longer
timeline but
needless to say the analysis is correct
alexander bolton goes on to say now
republicans are having a tough time
generating the same outrage over biden's
multi-trillion dollar spending agenda as
they did over former president obama's
signature initiatives the american
relief and reinvestment act and the
affordable care act which cost far less
than what biden is proposing on
infrastructure i think that there's
another aspect to that i don't think
that it's because of republican
hypocrisy
that now they aren't that opposed or
actually are in favor of joe biden's 1.9
1.9 trillion dollar stimulus or joe
biden's planned infrastructure spending
which also has some significant
republican support it's not that
republicans are saying
you know when trump blew up the deficit
we were okay with it so maybe joe biden
doing it isn't so bad i don't think it's
that at all
it's that the country
is actually just all united on those
issues and always has been
and the political clout or influence
that the republican party had
by criticizing the spending is simply
not having the same impression i don't
think it's the voters that have changed
i think it's that the republican elected
officials have become less able to
generate outrage over it we've seen no
evidence that they actually care about
the hypocrisy it's just that the
republican party given everything that's
going on given how even many in the
republican party electorate now
understand that huge income inequality
is not so good they understand that you
know deficit just for the sake of saying
deficit is bad is not something most of
them are falling for i think that it's
the electorate that has actually uh um
uh
come to realize that they've been fed bs
by their party not that their views have
dramatically changed and it it used to
be
a sort of rallying cry that really got
people fired up and now it's just not if
you go back
eisenhower
was the last republican president to
preside over a balanced budget he
balanced the budget in 1956 and 1957 and
since then it's been two democrats that
balanced the budget lbj in 69 and
clinton during 1998 to 2001 followed by
george w w bush taking over and
exploding the deficit so
when you look at how the balanced budget
actually is far more common under
democratic presidents than republicans
you realize that the republican party's
two main economic policies cut taxes and
spend on the military
don't actually count as fiscal
conservatism they were never really
about fiscal conservatism they were
about
talking about fiscal conservatism and
then a basic you know finance 101 econ
101 when you say okay the policy is you
cut taxes as much as possible
reduce revenue
and then you spend more on the military
that that's not actually fiscally
conservative and now they're not even
pretending to be about that so i i agree
very much with what alexander bolton
concludes here which is the republican
party
is right to worry that fiscal
conservatism as a rallying cry and
unifying sort of policy it's not even
really a policy idea it's it's a
framework it's a bullet point of some
kind uh it's no longer working and you
have
many republicans approving of biden's
stimulus plan many republicans approving
of biden's proposed infrastructure plan
they're going to have to come up with
something else
they seem to be going in the direction
of making it these culture issues the
question is whether even that will work
because support for movements like black
lives matter
is up even among the right not by that
much
not by that much but all of the
hammering on blm by the right
hasn't decreased support hasn't
increased much but it hasn't decreased
it so i don't actually know what they
need to do to win the hearts and minds
of voters which explains perfectly why
they are focusing on suppressing the
vote
they're they're realizing they're having
trouble winning any other way and so you
suppress the vote you try to win in that
way and that's exactly what they
admitted they were going to do back in
2012 you go to the video of mike turzai
pennsylvania saying voter id is going to
help mitt romney win some states that's
not mitt romney's going to come up with
great ideas it's not mitt romney
understands what it is that the average
american wants it's voter id will help
mitt romney win it didn't he lost badly
to barack obama but this was all
predictable it's been predictable for a
decade and it is happening right now the
question is
do they double down on the voter
suppression or do they start trying to
win on policy it seems that they're
doing the voter suppression
there's a clip of former republican
senator rick santorum making the rounds
in which he seems to either forget
or pretend not to remember
that when europeans came to what is now
the united states there were native
americans here already there were
societies and cultures and communities
already rick santorum is a really gross
guy he's been a cnn contributor for some
time since he left the senate listen to
what he had to say to the young americas
foundation about the united states and
its uniqueness if you think about this
country i don't know of any other
country in the world that was settled
predominantly by people who were coming
to practice their faith
they came here because they were not
allowed to practice their particular
faith in their own country and so they
came here mostly from europe
and they set up a country
that was based on judeo-christian
principles
i say judeo-christ the mosaic laws ten
commandments
and the teachings of jesus christ the
morale the morals and teachings of jesus
christ that's that's what our founding
documents are based upon
it's in our dna you know if you think of
other countries like italy and greece
and china and turkey and places like
that
they've all sort of
changed over time
i mean they've been they've been there
for cent for millennia in many cases
and their culture has sort of evolved
over time
but not us
we came here
and created a blank slate we birthed a
nation from nothing i mean there's
nothing here i mean yes we have native
americans but but candidly that that
there isn't much native american culture
in american culture so there's a lot
there and we will get into it but what i
was struck by in watching the clip is
how so much of what these right wingers
consider their values and principles are
based on faulty understandings of
history where their logic is often
functioning in reverse i'll give you an
example rick santorum says there isn't
much native american culture in american
culture he says that to defend his claim
that there really wasn't anything here
when europeans came to what is now the
united states and had what was here when
they arrived been more valuable we would
still see much more native american
cultural influence today it's completely
backwards reasoning
there isn't much native american culture
today because native americans were
widely exterminated their land taken and
we simply destroyed their culture and
overran it his reasoning is the fact
that not much of their culture is left
is evidence that there wasn't much
interesting about it when in fact the
reason there isn't much left is american
settlers decided to get rid of it but
it's a pretty grim insight into how rick
santorum views the people that were here
when european settlers arrived which is
there wasn't much of value to him
based on his values which are the
judeo-christian stuff that he said
about the founding of the united states
of america the truth is there was
culture there was infrastructure there
were communities there were customs none
of it was of any value to people like
rick santorum now if you're interested
in learning more about this the book
1491
gives you a real sense
of the americas
before european settlers landed but
there's this kind of interplay between
rick santorum's religious beliefs
serving as a justification for what
happened here and what happened here
then becomes a justification for his
religious views it's this closed loop
that can't be broken doxastic closure is
the term i've used in the past to
describe it and then we get to the
bigger picture message which is this is
just another example of how these
right-wingers are incredibly staunch in
their beliefs because they think they
know what those beliefs are based on but
it turns out their beliefs are based on
misunderstandings and errors it's you
know i've talked i've jokingly talked
before about
what's the next principled stance ted
cruz will take based on something he
misheard or misunderstood
this is a really tough cycle to break
because first you have to look at their
premises and take them down one by one
actually there were communities and
cultures and tons of things here
actually we are responsible for getting
rid of those things and so actually the
situation of the u.s is getting to where
it is today
isn't that unique and it's certainly not
particularly heroic it has a lot of ugly
in the past and it has a ton of
innovation of course
this applies to a lot of the modern
right-wing set of beliefs taxes are bad
for the economy and so democrats are bad
for wanting higher taxes and so the
economy also will do poorly under
democrats whoa hold on a second
actually well-calibrated and
well-balanced taxation is good for the
country the stock market has done better
under democrats it's a lot of work as
many of you know who have tried to
convince you know your crazy right-wing
uncle at thanksgiving it's a lot of work
to get people to change their minds on
these things and of course
this particular example for rick
santorum also has him it's all kind of
draped in his religious beliefs both to
justify his religious beliefs
and to glorify them and this is what
they do unless we tell people otherwise
and even when we tell people otherwise
often they keep doing it anyway so this
this is tough i've not found the
solution on this we've spoken to social
psychologists we've spoken to um
you know so many different people
about changing minds
and when it's this deep it is very
difficult and we're going to see really
a horrifying example of this
after the next dinner after the next
segment in the last segment of the show
a really horrible example of this from
tucker carlson unmasking so that's later
make sure you're following us on
instagram for more on this story
we are on instagram at david pakman show
you can find me on instagram at
david.pakman
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show has been and continues
to be
membership and membership is not just a
feel-good thing you get access to the
world famous bonus show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly at
joinpacman.com that's join
pakman.com if the normal prices strike
you as high by all means use the coupon
code better21 all one word all lowercase
become a member today today i'm going to
be speaking with mike rinder who's a
former senior executive of the church of
scientology as well as the sea
organization
uh mike it's so great to have you on
today
thanks david it's lovely to be here so
i've interviewed both first and second
generation scientology members i know
that often the dynamics for one's
relationship to scientology are
different depending on whether your
parents
were were uh um already part of it when
you were born or not talk to us a little
bit about your path in
okay i'm a second generation
scientologist my parents got involved in
scientology in australia
when hubbard went there to do some
lectures in 1959 and
so from a very young age i was raised in
a scientology family and then
uh once i finished high school i joined
what's called the sea organization which
is the
like the elite in a core of scientology
people that devote their entire lives to
uh
supposedly achieving the aims of the
religion they sign a billion-year
contract yep billion
because scientologists believe that you
live many different lifetimes and your
spirit transcends bodies and so you
commit yourself basically to
an eternity of service of scientology
and i did that from the age of uh 18
until
i left when i was 53.
so there there's already five branching
paths we we could go down here let's
let's address a few maybe of the the the
sort of uh nuts and bolts you say when
you finished high school is scientology
big on people that are part of the sea
org
not going to college
absolutely
how about i mean everything in
scientology is based on what hubbard's
view of things are and
hubbard had a very negative opinion of
uh
educational
systems and educational institutions
partly because he dropped out of college
but also he figured that he had
come up with a tech a quote technology
of study
that made everything else sort of
irrelevant and because he believed that
scientology addresses everything there
is to know about life and the world
that
it was far more important for children
to be educated in scientology than
educated in
quote [ __ ] meaning non-scientology
stuff
got it and then in terms of the sea org
i know that other sea org former sea org
folks i've spoken to
say they got no salary they basically
got housing and then that was part of
the way that the church would exert
control over them was that your
situation
yeah absolutely david that's every
everybody who is in the sea organization
is becomes basically an indentured
servant right the
to the organization of scientology in
other words
you live you eat your health care
whatever it may be is provided by
scientology
you don't earn
uh money per se you get what's called a
stipend which can range from
nothing to
fifty dollars a week maybe if you're
lucky
and
you so
you have no resources available you most
ceo members do not own a vehicle
they don't own a house they don't have
any
sort of worldly means many of them uh
joined the sea organization even younger
than i did they don't even have a high
school diploma they don't have any
anything
that
allows them or would allow them to walk
out into the real world and
carry on a normal life so
the fear within the sea organization and
it's something that is
cultivated is that stepping outside of
the sea organization is going to be
a tan amount to committing suicide
you know there's this old uh joke not so
much a joke but a statement that goes
around in the in the sea org is if you
leave the sea org all you'll do is end
up living under a bridge or flipping
burgers at mcdonald's
that you don't have any
any other avenue to pursue in life other
than what we are offering you
so at some point you start to work your
way up
and you start to actually uh you you
eventually become chief spokesperson and
representative of scientology to the
media
at that point or maybe to put it a
different way at what point did you
start to have doubts about your
everything that you were doing and what
you had been told
i started to have doubts um
probably about five years before i left
and i left in 2007 so in the early 2000s
but you have to understand david that
having doubts is
there is this enormous push and pull
of
what you've been taught in scientology
and there is a very fundamental
principle that hubbard uses to
you know hang on to people which is
that your condition whatever whatever
condition you find yourself in is your
own
you've caused that
that you've caused if it's a bad state
of affairs you've caused it by doing bad
things
and so
when you
and it even is down to the level of if
you're contemplating leaving this
organization it means that you've done
bad things to this organization
so you get this push and pull oh my god
something's wrong here oh my scientology
teaching tells me that that's because
i've done something bad and i need to
look inside within myself and figure out
what that is
so
and there are a lot of other factors
that go into it like i had two children
and a wife if i
decide i wish to leave
then
that becomes a problem because if i tell
my wife she's probably going to report
me
and then i'll be stopped
if i
don't tell her i'm going to lose my wife
and children so
there's a and and that's just the sort
of most surface factors so talk a little
bit about the concept i've heard before
about i will be prevented from leaving
and what i want to understand is as a
general thing someone calls the police
and says they're being held against
their will for example and police show
up and and you know you don't even
really need a warrant in that situation
you're able to verify someone's
well-being did you even have access to a
phone could you even call police if
you're being held against your will
well this this depends on where you're
at if you were where i was at golden era
productions the international
headquarters of scientology in riverside
county
you don't have commonly access to a
phone and the phones that are there in
order to be able to make any call you
have to go via reception i see but
beneath that david is there is another
very well
inculcated idea in scientology that
going to the police or law enforcement
is a big no no
this is just not done nobody
goes to
call the police or
do something
that is outside of the world of
scientology to solve a problem within
scientology now obviously
if you're
if you're at the point where you're
ready to jump the fence and run down the
the highway in the middle of nowhere and
hope that someone's going to pick you up
then you're not in that mindset but it
takes a lot of
a lot of
uh
thinking outside the bubble that you
exist in
to get to that point right and by by
very definition because you're in a
bubble of
agreed upon thoughts and ideas and
everybody else agrees with you and
what's right and what's wrong is all
agreed upon it's very difficult to think
outside that bubble
so
that's it that's why larry wright so
cleverly called his book going clear
scientology and the prison of belief
because though there are security guards
there's lights there's motion sensors on
the fences there's cameras everywhere
etc etc the real prison of scientology
and particularly seo members is
here right and
did your some of the former scientology
people i've spoken to
started to take issue with the practices
as an organization but almost continued
having
the doctrine beliefs even after they
left were your doubts with one the other
or both
with primarily one the the organization
and david miscavige interesting so your
initial problem was not you didn't
believe the that aliens previously were
here or z you weren't doubting that you
were doubting the organization
correct
it takes and i you know i obviously have
spoken to a lot of former scientologists
and a lot of former sea og members
it's sort of like a stage of
uh peeling the onion of
unburdening yourself of ideas that have
been
sort of
built into your dna almost particularly
if you're raised that way
and the easiest ones are the ones that
have a very
physical manifestation
like
being beaten up by david miscavige is
something that's a very you know
tangible here and now thing
the ideas of that dianetics and
hubbard's book dianetics is a load of
bunk
takes a lot longer to get
sort of shed
because
it's it's not so it's not so tangible
that makes a lot of sense and i i mean
when when you
it it seems as though
it takes
in a sense more although in a physical
sense
the decision to leave or try to leave
uh seems like the piece that's most
difficult it seems that maybe the
beliefs that have been ingrained in you
your entire life are really the most
difficult although in a different way
yeah you're you're absolutely right
david
and i don't think that there is anybody
that you will ever talk to who is a
former scientologist that will tell you
anything different than that
you were a shared experience you you
talk talk about what it means to be in
the hole and your experience in the hole
for two years
um well it's really a prison it was a a
prison that was created at the
international headquarters by david
miscavige in a
uh double-wide trail a building that was
constructed out of two double wide
trailers and the doors were bad and the
windows were screwed shut and
there was a security guard at the only
access point to the building and
we were put in there to
um
figure out why we were suppressive
persons and a suppressive person in
scientology means
someone who is intent upon destroying
mankind right and
miscavitch
david miscavige the the
ecclesiastical leader of the scientology
religion as he likes to call himself
was um
always
seeking to
be the person who was
the doc the big dog the dominant
personality in the environment and kept
anybody who was
a potential threat to his control of the
organization
constantly in a state of am i in trouble
am i not in trouble am i going to be you
know sent to to
shovel in louisiana am i
am i in good graces today and
the whole was sort of the final
manifestation of this where he basically
took everybody who was at the senior
echelon of scientology and put them in
this prison and said
when you guys figure out
why you're so bad maybe you can get out
right and
that devolved in this
you know
going clear gives a pretty good
depiction of some of what happened the
the alex gibney movie the hbo movie
but
the the the truth of the matter is it
devolved into a sort of a lord of the
flies world of
people striving to demonstrate to david
miscavige
that they were more on his team than
anybody else
by
attacking the other people and saying
you know you're a bad person or beating
them up or yelling at them or you know
famously in the case of debbie cook who
was put there and testified on the stand
that she was put in a garbage can with a
sign around her neck and people poured
water over her until she was shivering
in
and
being
physically and and verbally abused
this happened as the sort of
um
routine
that ended up being in the hull and it
was pretty
pretty uh
both bizarre and
horrifying and shocking and
uh
a little unbelievable to think that that
uh could be happening in today's
united states of america yeah well i
think that's that's the question a lot
of people in the audience have which is
how is how is it happening we're going
to continue our conversation and the
full conversation will be posted on our
youtube channel we're going to go to a
break on the podcast tv and radio show
uh we've been speaking of course with
mike rinder a former senior executive of
the church of scientology and the sea
org the full conversation will be on our
youtube channel
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month plus you can get
the daily bonus show world famous at
this point and the daily commercial free
tv show by making those pledges at
patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners whether you
listen to the podcast watch on youtube
or watch us on tv or even listen on the
radio patreon.com slash david pakman
show we are now getting to the point of
being able to talk about easing mass
guidelines joe biden in fact today is
set to make a statement about masking as
a follow-up to what we're expecting to
be an easing of outdoor mass guidelines
by the cdc i already said yesterday this
makes absolutely perfect sense based on
the science tucker carlson on fox news
cannot simply leave it at that tucker
has to go further and not only attack
masking but demand that people bully
mask wearers if they see them wearing
masks if they want to
let's jump right into this segment from
last night uh first part of the segment
as we did give in this grotesque version
of halloween went on for more than a
year and it's still going on
not even tony fauci still pretends that
mass are medically necessary instead
mass are purely a sign of political
obedience like kim il-sung pins and
pyongyang
we wear them because we have to the only
people who wear masks voluntarily
outside are zealots and neurotics how
neurotic are they
well we know a pew survey from last
march found that 64
of white americans who classify
themselves as liberal or very liberal
have been diagnosed with an actual
mental health condition
and you see them everywhere when you
walk down the street in any major city
now the mental health thing is very
deceptive and ugly he doesn't mention
what portion of all americans have been
diagnosed and even diagnosed as a
complicated term because lots of people
have undiagnosed mental illness because
they refuse to go or don't have access
to mental health care and also simply
being anxious counts as mental illness
in the poll that tucker mentions that's
all deceptive and very ugly and sort of
used as a cudgel
but tucker carlson is right about one
thing there's an aspect in which masks
are theater i've been talking about it
outdoors
on bike paths and sidewalks especially
after vaccination there is an element to
masks being a theater it's a signal that
you care
before anybody was vaccinated
one out of a thousand cases were
transmitted outdoors
and they were in obvious situations
people crowded together in large groups
outdoors no one is getting this walking
by someone on the sidewalk even jogging
by someone check out the recent
statements from dr ashish jah from brown
university i never believed that that
made sense but i did it to show i care
so in a sense there is an aspect of
theater but we're getting beyond that
now and it's a good thing but somehow
tucker is attacking people's mental
health and then it gets much worse
if you dare to go on foot from union
station to the capitol for example in
washington without wearing a mask
angry biden voters will snort at you in
judgment how could you they're saying
from behind the gauze
how could you that's the question we
should be asking of them in return the
rest of us should be snorting at them
first they're the aggressors it's our
job to brush them back and restore the
society we were born in
so the next time you see someone in a
mask on the sidewalk or on the bike path
do not hesitate ask politely but firmly
would you please take off your mask now
this is really stupid i'm ready to stop
wearing my mask outdoors based on the
coming cdc and joe biden statements i
expect governors
to go with outdoor masking is not needed
but other people wearing them why do i
care if other people are wearing masks
but if it's the middle of summer and i
see somebody wearing a winter hat i
think that's odd
uh it doesn't seem comfortable but what
difference does it make to me if someone
wants to wear a wool winter hat
in the middle of summer go ahead and do
it as long as you don't make me do it i
think the judgment of people
not wearing masks outdoors as these
guidelines ease
is something that will have to be dealt
with but tell other people to take off
masks it doesn't really sound like
liberty and freedom even that uh
so-called conservatives advocate for
that's not making sense and then it just
gets worse
science shows there is no reason for you
to be wearing it your mask is making me
uncomfortable
we should do that and we should keep
doing it until wearing a mask outside is
roughly as socially accepted as lighting
a marble in an elevator
it's repulsive don't do it around other
people
that's the message we should send
because it's true
i don't know if tucker believes that
quite frankly like i think he knows his
audience will love it
but then to actually go into how to deal
with kids wearing masks he says call
child services
as for forcing children to wear mass
outside that should be illegal
your response when you see children
wearing masks as they play should be no
different from your response to seeing
someone beat a kid in walmart call the
police immediately contact child
protective services keep calling until
someone arrives
what you're looking at is abuse it's
child abuse and you are morally
obligated to attempt to prevent it
if it's your own children being abused
then act accordingly
let's say your kid's school emailed you
to announce that every day after lunch
your sixth grader was going to get
punched in the face by a teacher
how would you respond to that
that's precisely how you should respond
when they tell you that your kids have
to wear masks on the soccer field that
is unacceptable it is dangerous and we
should act like it because it is
but too few of us have responded like
that so that is just completely off the
rails tucker starts with the kernel of a
good idea
science doesn't support the need for
outdoor masking great crossover
agreement i will join tucker in a
bipartisan way on that issue
then he drops in 64 of liberals are
mentally ill oh wait hold on where is
this going
then he goes in to tell other people to
take off their masks
because you don't like it well hold on
now that's authoritarian and overbearing
and then called child protective
services if you see a kid wearing a mask
hello police
get cps here there's mask wearing on a
playground
what we need instead
are just clear
new guidelines from the cdc
not to weaponize mask wearing against
people by involving child services or
police that's not that far from like
alex jones type stuff about putting kids
in camps or whatever it's like a soft
alex jones with better writing lighting
and makeup that's essentially what
tucker carlson has become
and the colonel was was not crazy
uh about outdoor masking and the cdc is
set to agree with the colonel of that
and then it just goes completely off the
rails my question is do you think tucker
believes this stuff or tucker's doing it
because he knows his audience will
absolutely love it i don't know let me
know what you think
yesterday we talked about the completely
bogus conspiracy theory that spread like
wildfire this weekend that joe biden
wants to take away red meat and even
plant-based uh will force plant-based
beer on people which we know of as beer
as part of his climate plan and the
talking point included
that joe biden's climate plan would
reduce each american's so-called meat
allowance to four pounds of red meat per
year we already talked about it
yesterday it's completely false but that
didn't stop endless tweets and tv
segments about it congresswoman lauren
bobert tweeted about it and just
accepted the premises hook line and
sinker donald trump jr tweeted about it
and indeed the source on this stuff was
listed on air on fox news as the
department of agriculture
of the university of michigan now as i
told you yesterday this is a study of
hypothetical changes from the university
of michigan from last year from before
joe biden even being president it has
nothing to do with joe biden's plan
which is simply the the the study simply
said
if people did x
the result on emissions would be y
has nothing to do with joe biden
whatsoever
now fox news anchor john roberts
admitted on air yesterday that he pushed
a completely basis claim on friday i
call this lying about joe biden trying
to require americans to reduce meat
consumption as part of his climate plan
here is the apology which of course
makes no mention of the fact that there
were three days of news coverage and
apoplectic republicans which were
catalyzed by the pathetic segment that
john roberts did on friday here is the
retraction if you want to call it that
on friday we told you about a study from
the university of michigan to give some
perspective on president biden's
ambitious climate change goals that
research from 2020 found that cutting
back how much red meat people eat would
have a drastic impact on harmful
greenhouse gas emissions the data was
accurate but a graphic and a script
incorrectly implied that it was part of
biden's plan for dealing with climate
change that
is not the case
okay so at least he took it back but the
retraction is sort of convoluted and
quick it barely even really mentions
what happened and the damage is done the
genie is out of the bottle you can't
unring a bell very few people see the
correction it's much too late
and it's almost the strategy they will
knowingly make 10 ridiculous claims
about democrats biden obama the left
they know that they're false
some they will get called out on one
might explode so badly that three days
later they do a take back but they've
succeeded overall at getting the talking
points out they spend hours on multiple
programs all weekend making the same
accusations and then on monday you get
one short retraction remember that judge
jeanine pirro covered the same story
remember these clips i played them for
you yesterday finally tonight
do you like red meat
so
the cows must go yeah i like burgers and
i like my gas powered car and i'm sick
of chyna having the upper hand over us
what about judge jeanine's retraction
even if she does one it's only a weekly
show she's not back until the weekend
it's almost perfect you tell the lie
friday afternoon
you set off a weekend of coverage
you quietly retracted on monday on one
show only and by then millions of right
wingers believe it don jr has tweeted
about it they've all signal boosted it
and nothing comes of the attempt and
it's pretty flaccid and as far as an
attempt goes to correct the record what
john roberts did was lie
and it's a retraction it's convoluted
but that is what he is in practice
actually admitting to here and of course
we knew the story was false all along
there just was nothing to it
we have a voicemail number that you can
call that number is 2192 david p
here's a good question about a term that
many right-wingers have been using
lately take a listen to this hey david i
was just watching your bit on
uh the the fake scandals that fox news
is trying to conjure up and there was a
bit in your video about new gringage
um
basically saying
that the
gay flag
flying at embassies is going against
traditional values as he says well what
is traditional values or sometimes i
hear it as traditional family values yes
i hear these terms thrown around a lot
by republicans usually in the sense that
someone
someone else
goes against what they believe
is this something that the right demands
in order to be an american when you fly
a gay flag that goes against someone
else's i'm assuming their religion
does that not make you an american yeah
well so what they
the question of what they mean by
traditional values or traditional family
values is a good one
there's a bunch of interpretations but
my understanding of traditional family
values is basically a 1950s era
perspective of you're starting to get
some uh equality and egalitarianism
between men and women
but there's still a male dominated
aspect to society
you are
starting there's no slavery in the 1950s
but there's still all sorts of racial
discrimination
um abortion has not yet been established
uh as legal through roe v wade it for me
it's a 1950s era of view
either proactive or sort of by default
when i hear of traditional values or
traditional family values if you see it
a different way
not we don't yet have enshrined rights
for lgbt individuals if you see it
differently let me know but that's what
i think of when i hear about traditional
family values we have a great bonus show
for you today the supreme court is going
to hear a case
on the right to carry concealed guns for
self-defense
important case we will discuss it
in new zealand 50 000 people attended a
rock concert why because they've gotten
rid of the virus in new zealand we will
talk about that and the census bureau
has announced the us has 331 million
people living in it and texas will get
two congressional seats
very important in terms of the possible
future balance of power in the house of
representatives all of these stories and
more on today's bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpacman.com i will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman